you know this is this is really about
asking for help you know this is a time
of vulnerability we feel vulnerable our
lives are shattered strengths we had
competences we had are shaken and and
and this is a time to embrace
vulnerability you know you know the the
hubris of leadership or the houmous in
leadership I should say you know there
are many leaders in in in premiums are
like thought that they could do it all
and everyone else is disposable and now
you're recognizing now we're recognizing
that none of us can do this alone this
is gonna take help because we're working
at such a furious pace there's too much
going on and too many balls in the air
that no one person can juggle them all
and if we want to work to save jobs and
save lives literally and figuratively
then then we have no choice than to say
to the people we work with I cannot do
this alone
III need I need your help I I I'm not
strong enough to do this alone but I
know that as a team we are strong enough
to do this together and I think that
that that humility and that
vulnerability and the willingness to
embrace the the strength of others is
what we need now more than ever
[Music]
you